all right the Ahsoka series it's half
over now episodes one through four have
aired season one or or the entire series
if it's a limited series of Ahsoka it's
a season five of rebels is half over I
was gonna do a video on the first two
episodes because that's what aired and I
was like but I just don't care then
after last week I was like all right
episodes one two three gonna do it still
don't care but this is a day wedged
between a couple of weeks in which there
wasn't a lot to do with video One gotta
feed the YouTube algorithm God so here
we are and for my part the first half of
Ahsoka
it's meh but it is Star Wars meh that
always feels a bit worse first of all
spoilers for Ahsoka episodes one through
four are not gonna be a play-by-play in
fact there are a lot of play-by-plays on
the internet I don't want to redundantly
regurgitate what they've already said
which is gonna give you my thoughts I'll
actually have more thoughts than I put
in this video happens every video I'll
be in bed the next night and be like ah
forgot to say that but it is what it is
spoiler warning you've been warned gonna
get this out of the way right now yes
the end of episode four did have some
really fun member Berry soup
that's nice but this stuff doesn't work
on me as well as it used to something
about this Elixir I've found that
negates the effects first of all
speaking of the mail why is it mad
because the characters in this show just
seem bored I mean you're springboarding
off of the Animated Series Rebels and
the animated counterparts are far more
lively lifelike and interesting than the
live-action counterpart everyone stands
with their arms folded to soak is always
like
just looks like her contact lenses hurt
like she's like oh God [__] I hate this
contact let's just hurt my eyes funny
enough Rosario Dawson in Daredevil is a
better Ahsoka than she is in Ahsoka
which means she was a good pick but
someone out there was like Hey can you
just not be the reason you were cast I
mean it feels like they're trying to
make Ahsoka this wiser seasoned Jedi
Master version of Ahsoka but it feels
like it was written by an AI algorithm
that assessed a Jedi Council meeting and
was like that's how Jedi Masters act and
talk Ahsoka is kinda like a Jedi master
that's how Ahsoka Tano acts and talks
doesn't make sense for her character and
she comes across as boring not just her
though there are a few elements of this
show it feels like it was written by AI
I mean right from the opening crawl of
Ahsoka which isn't really a Star Wars
opening crawl it feels like an AI
algorithm
assess that Star Wars has an opening
crawl but it doesn't know the difference
between a Star Wars opening crawl and a
conventional opening crawl there's a map
leading to thrawn another map leading to
a person it's like Disney Star Wars
isn't even stealing from other Star Wars
It's stealing from itself now Disney
Star Wars is redoing Disney Star Wars
It's a snake eating its own tail the
coolest characters for me are Ray
Stevenson and his little Apprentice it
looks like she cuts her own hair with a
Flowbee kind of has crazy eyes never
blinks like she's Christopher Lloyd from
Who Framed Roger Rabbit or something she
just looks like an apprentice who's been
an apprentice for 20 years and never
been promoted but I thought they were
great there are conveniences wrapped
into them like people just shooting at
Ray Stevenson's lightsaber specifically
the game is to shoot the lightsaber not
the person right it was not a [__]
there's something about his character
like he's not a Sith he's not a Jedi
he's just
kind of an [__] but he makes remarks
like there's so few Jedi left you know
it it's almost like he's lamenting the
Jedi and I really love that scene where
he's like Sabine give me the sphere and
I will [__] the Galaxy but you might
have a possibility of seeing your friend
again real thank you glad you did that
then his Apprentice was force holding
Sabine and he was like let her go I gave
her my word that's amazing antagonist
yes he is but he's an antagonist with
Integrity I appreciate characters who
operate within a code the guy's word is
his bond I respect that are he and his
Apprentice the two most interesting
characters in this entire thing
yes it's not even close should the show
have been about them but it's not it's
Rebels season five that's also another
problem this show is Rebels season five
but it's called Ahsoka it operates as
though you know the characters from
Rebels and it's just picking up where
Rebels left off and we're going forward
we don't need a reintroduction of the
characters but you do we've been told
how scary thrawn is and how important it
is he doesn't come back but if you
haven't seen Rebels you don't know
because I was watching this show and I
was like I'll be honest I have no memory
of that I've watched the whole I've
watched Rebels right when the [__] did
Ahsoka train Sabine as a jet when did
that happen I had to do a Google search
like did I sleep through the lesson oh
no that just never happened they just
made it up because the AI algorithm that
wrote this show was like Jedi have an
apprentice always two there are
obviously
Sabine That's The Apprentice it really
is kind of a no-win scenario either
you're gonna have Sabine have the force
which just feels like like you're
rewriting her character or you're gonna
have Sabine not have the force and be
like I'm a Mandalorian I don't have the
force in which case what was the point
of Ahsoka training her in the first
place training her twice we're picking
up on the second time feels like a
massive waste of time damned if you do
damned if you don't that's just on the
writing I mean it looks like she kind of
force slapped for a second it was kind
of funny when they were training and I
was like I say what you're doing pulling
from 1977. it was cool in 1977 also the
blast shield down I can't even can't see
how am I supposed to fight however I
give Luke that pass because Luke 30
minutes ago learned about the force his
entire world perspective about life
death God the devil hell heaven his
father was flipped on its head he just
learned about the force with Sabine the
answer would be very simple well you
remember your friend the blind Jedi you
know that [__] can work she knows the
force can work like that I was just
baffled nobody brought up Kanan as a
rebuttal that's when Ahsoka should have
called it should have been like look
this is the second time I've tried to
train you apparently so the audience
hears about once they've actually seen
and I'm just saying you're not gonna
learn through the experience of your
life this is not gonna work look here's
a real question
how does Ray Stevenson's character know
Anakin Skywalker was Darth Vader because
he clearly knows per what he was saying
to Ahsoka in episode 4. that's one of
the problems you run into when you
expand Star Wars lore you expand the
storytelling you do it among many
different writers but there's no real
guard rail everyone has their own Vision
as to what the future is supposed to be
and who's supposed to know what and what
was supposed to happen after the empire
fell and the right hand doesn't know
what the left is doing so you just have
conflicting lower that Snake Eyes
Inquisitor character from GI Joe he was
kind of cool that was the character that
was getting everybody to theorize like
oh who is it is it Starkiller but we all
knew satisfaction is the death of Desire
the reality is never going to be as cool
as the theories sure enough he got slash
turned into smoke and that was that
I don't know if Disney Star Wars meant
to create a perfect Disney Star Wars
allegory but there it was really cool
looking fun to theorize about but in the
end it was just smoking nothingness to
its core and I won't lie I was thinking
okay Ahsoka was trained in Clone Wars
time prequel time the prequels had the S
tier the god-tier lightsaber battles
maybe we'll get a bit of that here nope
not really Ahsoka episode 4 did have the
better of the lightsaber battles in the
Ahsoka series but still it was nowhere
near Phantom Menace or Revenge of the
Sith which is another problem when
you're dealing with one movie in a
Trilogy and there's no other Star Wars
out there you can have the actors commit
a lot more time two lightsaber fights
and yeah the new Republic just looked
like a bunch of [__] episode three
they just look like a bunch of pompous
dicks I guess they're trying to show
like yeah that kind of hubris is what
made the new Republic fail I didn't know
this why they failed I just thought some
years after the Rebellion took out the
Space Nazis space Isis shot of
hyperspace Cannon and all the new
Republic worlds wiping it all out and
that's how it felt not because their
pompous dicks another problem with what
I was talking about earlier the right
hand not knowing what the left is doing
you have multiple writers being like
okay this is what was happening after
the empire fell it really feels like the
world of rebels is so disconnected from
the characters from the original trilogy
and they're both existing in tandem the
crew of the original trilogy isn't
around when the biggest threat to the
Galaxy is apparently about to happen
which is Grand Admiral thrawn coming
back so at the end of all this Sabine
gives the McGuffin to the baddies and
it's like I really want to see my
friends
I might have [__] the Galaxy but I
really want to see my friend Ahsoka gets
thrown over a cliff something that has
happened to her a million times I wasn't
even worried about it point is she wakes
up in this space from Rebels
and you hear Anakin and I hope she has
questions for him that I have and I hope
he has questions for her that I also
have I hope she looks right at him and
is like master
why does your Force ghost have a robot
arm you see as much as I have wanted to
see Anakin Skywalker come to Ahsoka Tano
and Luke Skywalker I mean we saw that at
the end of Return of the Jedi a bit but
I mean
in a larger capacity of conversation as
much as we've wanted to see that again
the AI that wrote It's like fans want
that here but no it needs to be in a
world of consistency because a world of
consistency is a sane world it's a it's
a world that makes sense and with Force
ghosts
nothing is consistent
and by God I wish it was assuming of
course this was an Anakin Skywalker
Force ghost I mean it's not glowing or
anything it could be a hallucination for
all I know if you're Ahsoka Tano you can
see your former master of many years
once in the world in Between Worlds
during a near-death experience for a
much Greener Luke Skywalker you can see
Obi-Wan Kenobi who you knew for about a
day in fact anyone could just show up
and drop nuggets at any time but if
you're Obi-Wan Kenobi the Force ghost of
your master can only come to you after
you face the cyborg [__] version of
your former apprentice and best friend
but he was always there because he'll
tell you that so there's no real
consistency with Force ghost there's no
set of rules that we can look at and be
like that's how Force goes to operate
but I do hope Anakin Skywalker has the
question for Ahsoka that I have which is
hey Snips when you learned this great
threat to the Galaxy existed which was
the possible return of grand Admiral
thrawn thus the possible Return of the
Galactic Empire
why did you not seek the aid of my son
Luke Skywalker who you know helped
defeat the Empire he helped turn me good
I threw the emperor down a shaft he
exploded he's never coming back trust
that
trust it it's just it's only [__]
logical I know you've hung out with him
if Qui-Gon was watching Obi-Wan I was
watching that [__] but in the end you
thought to yourself yep that would be a
smart thing to do
two Jedi are better than one but how
about one Jedi and one young Mandalorian
trying to move cups with the force I
mean the show is called Ahsoka in that
you gotta take the story where Ahsoka
would be I don't know that she would be
hanging out with the rebels crew at this
point I feel like it's more likely she'd
be hanging out with Luke Skywalker
helping to re-establish a new Jedi Order
the show Ahsoka should be Luke and
Ahsoka out there on an adventure that
means yes you gotta recast original
trilogy characters you gotta have a new
person play Luke so be it better than
hanging out with a half asleep half
bored Rebels crew being like why are we
all here man I haven't even touched on
the fact that Sabine gets scared by a
lightsaber and is fine lining up the
time stamp right about there her inside
should look like that what are the odds
what's the over under thrawn comes back
and these Imperial loyalists are like
all right we gotta Rebrand the Empire
because it kind of leaves a bad taste in
people's mouths so uh renaming this new
Empire is your first
order
not bad what are the odds that's how it
goes to oh God that's possible
oh God you know when you say something
as a joke then you realize how possible
it actually is so that's my thoughts on
Ahsoka it's meh Star Wars meh hurts a
little worse but men nonetheless Ray
Stevenson his Apprentice those
characters are the best ones in the
series also Ray Stevenson Gone Too Soon
first time I saw him was a Titus pillow
in Rome he was so good but a lot of the
rest of the characters yeah they
generally look bored yeah unless this
looks interested
and it doesn't if it did I would cross
my arms when I talk about movies on
YouTube I don't because it looks and
makes me feel like I'm uninterested so
the first half of Ahsoka episodes one
through four have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]